what are some assumptions that people
associate with your height what sports I
play what type of sports do they ask you
uh you play they involve balls
sure I'm so
excited hi I'm Tatiana I am 61 and just
in case I could ever forget that no one
else ever lets me forget it it's
impacted me my entire life I mean from
finding pants that are long enough to
dating and everything in between what's
up I'm Ryan uh short King here um
struggle is real I think it's a just a
perspective of kind of looking up at
everyone it's not really ideal so uh
neither is looking down so we'll see
let's do
it ready set
go D look at D beard oh my God
I don't know what I expected but it
wasn't that how y doing how y'all doing
do you have a strategy for this bro I
think we should just kind of like wing
it spit on and then like actually find
out just based on what we can see oh boy
I think you're tall you're a little tall
oh I feel like they're all tall now oh
my God this is hard it's Vibes right now
it's just Vibes he looks tall because
his head look at look at the shape of
the head it's just like fitting in it's
fitting in the hole I don't if that
sound weird but no that's fair I think
taller people in general exhibit a tend
to have longer faces okay you're going
to be mid to mid to end for me who do we
think is the shortest let's just pick
that did we say number four number four
is shortest based on Vibes I think
number three I think you might be a
little short too number three I can't
wait for you guys to prove us all wrong
okay number three number four can we go
shortest second shortest so one two
seven I feel like you're the tallest I
feel like he's really tall okay it's the
beard it's G like NBA energy too
okay okay you're getting moved don't
worry five mhm mhm yeah six seven six
okay there we go this is fun okay yay I
feel like we've made some mistakes but
we'll fix it in the second process trust
the process yes yeah all right yeah
there we
[Music]
go hi boys what's up okay I got some
questions for you guys for this size
matter wow what we about pacifically use
your imagination big dog we're talking
about height okay does height matter no
no don't think so that was quick I think
it's just the person H okay okay I think
it's yeah the person the personality I
think in some cases
yes I feel like it kind of depends who
you hang out with some people want you
to play basketball and some people don't
really need that height from you yeah
you're picking last right be like that
sometimes I think everything has its use
you know what I'm saying
right yeah makes sense so Dr Squatch
asked us if we were down to help our
viewers smell absolutely fantastic and
we were like yes absolutely so let's get
right into it right now Dr Squatch has a
deal going on for new customers that
when you buy three soaps you get three
more for free three for free I mean
that's so much for free you'll be saving
$28 which averages out to $4 per bar I
mean it's literally such a great deal if
you haven't heard about Dr Squatch
they're a men's natural soap line and
they have so many great scents to pick
from like cool fresh aloe which
literally transports me to a Desert
Oasis and then there's woodsy pine tar
which it's giving woodsy mountain man
these soaps leave me feeling and
smelling great and now is the best time
to try them out and all you have to do
is click the link in the description or
type drsquatch.com
Jubilee again you buy three and you get
three free three for free all right
that's enough for me thanks Dr squash
for sponsoring this video let's get back
to it what are some assumptions that
people associate with your height what
sports I play the wrong most of the time
so what type of sports do they ask you
uh you play they involve balls
sure I'd have to say they ask how much I
eat and I'm like you know good amount
enough enough exactly they assume that
like I'd be rude or mean or not
approachable I'm fast and I'm pretty
athletic too yeah that's what they kind
of get off first glance if you were to
work out what do you what would you
choose upper body or lower body that's a
that's a good one good lower body the
legs yeah if I'm working out I'm doing a
lower body that's what I'm talking about
leg down there baby yeah number two what
do you think upper body yeah what about
number three uh whatever gets me the
fattest ass I don't know period was baby
number seven do you think life would
improve if you were a different height I
think I would lose a lot of the things
that I'm capable of now so I'm good with
the height that I am it kind of looks
like Steph C how about number five um no
I'm I'm I'm satisfied with the head I am
number three same question do you think
life would improve if you were a
different
height
yeah hm number four uh I used to think
it would but I I feel like over the past
couple years I've gotten a lot more
comfortable of where I'm at what is the
first thing that people say when they
see you
generally he looks funny H you too same
actually H they used to say it's giving
hairy styles on wish.com oh my God not
wish the hair is giving hairy though I
love hairy um usually I think little
compliment my
outfit what kind of car you
have really damn that's the first thing
people say when they see you weird what
about you damn bro you're jacked nice
sure so out change three with five okay
go swap three with five
mhm okay why why did you switch those
too I mean works out legs cuz if you're
a shorter person you wouldn't really
focus on working out legs cuz it'd make
you look shorter clearly I've never
thought about that um here's the thing
right here's the gag Ry number three is
not short yes that's what I'm saying
that's why I said it was going to be
temporary love you I really do oh man I
know however there is no chance that
you're on the shorter end of the
spectrum I feel it maybe four I would
say right love you bro I really do our
new number five plays Sports it's the
only thing he's talked about the entire
episode and when I asked him which sport
it was he said that includes balls so I
don't play sports that include balls
they say do you play sports that balls
and I okay okay okay okay it's giv it's
giving swimmer and it's giving Michael
Phelps and it's giving long and that's
that's my new
[Music]
logic uh com from aore King are you guys
ever insecure about your height when I
was younger yes you made fun of a lot
yeah always being pushed into a locker
in middle
school I get that I get that I wasn't
but it wasn't until I think I realized
the way uh Society might think or have
certain um generalizations about people
of different heights that it kind of May
a bit insecure I'm chilling yeah my
sibling made me somewhat insecure about
my height I got to say that one thing
your sibling older or younger uh older
brother or sister brother sister oh
sister really okay yeah okay I get it oh
no sister that changes everything that
changes everything why would your sister
make fun of your height I never said she
made fun of it but she made me insecure
about it so she talked about it a lot
then either because he's like freakishly
tall or because he's I have a growing
feeling that number one is actually tall
people call you hairy styles like hairy
styles is tall I would know Harry if
you're watching is it just cuz of the
hair I think it's because of the style
no pun intended um I'm actually not
confident about number seven anymore I
think number seven and six need just
switch back at the very least maybe
change one to two let's switch one again
it's all Vibes I actually don't know can
I do I I'm going to yeah you can you can
switch that one too I feel like that's
like a safe you're
larger why does he give tall energy he
has tall energy he's just so nonchalant
I feel like you've never had to worry
about that ever in your life he doesn't
care you just have
zero shalant and I just it gives
basketball it's giving a little Steph
Curry you said that yeah I said Steph
Curry facial care whole VI no that's
feels right to you what if number five
was six ye
yeah okay okay I actually feel so
solidly that you're five
[Music]
here um do you care about height in your
partner I prefer same height or shorter
but as long as I can pick you up we're
good okay so yeah uh yeah I've dated
girls that are not my height like a wide
range of girls you could say I've only
dated short girls but I mean I'm pretty
confident to handle a tall girl number
four uh no preference you know I'm equal
on both I've
dated both equal amount of times as long
as they can wear heels and they're not
taller than me I'm a k fit but I do find
high attractive oh okay number one
honestly I don't it's like a buffet for
me I like seafood some days steak one
day and the bread with the honey spread
on other days my man okay that actually
That Shook some stuff up I think if
anyone's going to switch it's 5 and six
or 1 and two do you feel fine with that
can I switch one and two go for it I
want to switch one
to no I'm
not no I'm not I feel like switch two
and
[Music]
three camera
I dirty do you feel good about where
everyone's at before we lock it in I
would never feel good about this stuff
but yeah I guess this is what we're
going to go with I think we're confident
enough what do you think yeah I I feel
solid I think we're majority right so if
there's seven I think we have four in
the right place okay let's lock it in
and we will move on to the reveal can
our number one please come out oh what
at a time
F okay okay hey hey y'all okay so we
were right maybe who knows it's still
relative uh so my name is Sam I Am 5' 3
um and throughout my life uh my height
definitely has impacted me in many ways
from the way Society views men and the
way masculinity and femininity um kind
of go in line with ideas of height I
don't consider myself to be the most
masculine um person and because I'm
shorter too I think sometimes I get
afraid of tapping into the more feminine
side okay number two I love your thank
you oh
two I'm 510 my name's Karan um I've been
510 for a
minute that was the last minut switch
okay okay okay okay okay number
three I knew you were taller than I
thought you were hi my name is Tyler I'm
6'2 and uh yeah I was really short when
I was a kid so I got heavily bullied
until senior year I hit puberty she grew
exactly hairry Styles height number
four
what uh my name is Marcus um I'm 5'4 and
then I did lower body cuz I used to run
track okay okay yeah that's why I did
lower body number five damn damn
damn hi I'm Carter I'm 65 and you are
right I do swim that's my main sport
period it gave swimmer number six 65 I
think we're so unless there we go yeah
see I'm Isaac I'm 68 and called it being
cool number seven not number seven no
way all right number
[Music]
seven
what what hi I'm Anthony I've accepted
my height a long time ago and I actually
like being
short I think by by my height I'm
actually able to connect with people
more I don't scare people off and also I
train a lot of calisthenics so being
being short is kind of a a pro in that
sense I swore up and down I was like we
could get all them wrong number seven's
right you it was genuinely giving Steph
K the shot like I was like wow like word
yeah seven energy it was seven energy
that I'm sorry we did you so wrong man
that's why when I when I saw three I was
like dog okay but he change it lower I
was like oh all right were there any
frustrating moments for you as you were
being ranked I just felt like being
short was seen in such a Negative light
whenever ranks were being given they
were distributed in the sense of oh I'm
so sorry that I rated you shorter than
you actually are which I think speaks
volumes why do we feel that way or why
do we associate certain traits with
being tall and certain traits with being
short definitely underestimated
everybody's height it was the confidence
good stuff all of
you how do you guys feel after this
experience
exposed so I love it confidence shows
height I see so we here with it why do
you think confidence is associated with
height in our society cuz it's
associated with masculinity in the same
way that like people assumed as a tall
woman growing up or as a tall girl that
like I was insecure because I was tall
so I think I really focus on the things
right that are within my control
developing myself as a person being my
true self I made a lot of really special
connections with people look at all the
things that I'm able to do instead of
what I can't you know cuz height is the
one thing you can't change so let's see
everything else